[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 les invités émission
dédiée à celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans le département et nous
parlerons à politique et culture aussi
aujourd'hui avec philippe chevrier le
président du front libéré il entend
présenter des candidats aux élections
législatives de juin prochain dans les
yvelines dans les hauts-de-seine
également à l'ex responsable du parti
frontiste dans le département vient de
l'annoncer et nous expliquera pourquoi
et puis focus aussi sur le festival d
insensé en événement culturel
pluridisciplinaire qui se déroule à la
maison de l'étudiant de saint-quentin
jusqu'à la fin de la semaine son chef de
projet elle nous en dira plus bonsoir
philippe chevrier ancien responsable du
front national dans le département et
dorénavant président du front libéré
mouvements que vous avez décidé de
lancer et qui présentera des candidats
aux législatives dans deux départements
yvelines et hauts-de-seine
quel est l'objectif est ce que c'est un
sentiment de revanche qui vous anime
quelque part pas du tout mais bon
j'avais le choix entre rester à la
maison ou continuer à faire de la
politique
donc j'ai choisi de continuer à faire de
la politique parce que je pense qu'il ya
des choses à faire
ça vous a pas échappé que ce parti
s'appelle le fonds libérés donc il est
libéré de quelque chose et libérennes un
certain autoritarisme et d'un certain
fonctionnement de parti politique qui ne
touche pas que le front national soit j
avais demandé parce que le choix du nom
n'est pas anodin c'est une critique
envers le mode de fonctionnement du
front national du front national et des
autres partis parce que
quelqu'un d'ailleurs de très bien placés
en politique a parlé récemment de
démocratie intermittente c'est
exactement ce qu'on vit dans les partis
politiques est ce qu'on vit en france
c'est vrai que quand on élit un
président de la république c'est pour
cinq ans et pendant les cinq ans il fait
quasiment ce qu'il veut il faut bien le
reconnaître et dans les partis
politiques c'est un peu la même chose de
rosa et des congrès vous élisez des
présidents de parti et puis entre les
deux congrès le président du parti fait
un peu ce qu'il veut c'est ce que
j'appelle la démocratie intermittente
donc c'est ce qu'il faut changer à mon
avis pour que justement la gestion de la
france plus tard soit exercée d'une
manière plus démocratique
on va revenir sur vos ambitions sur
quelques points du programme aussi du
front libéré et puis sur les raisons de
votre exclusion pour ceux là qui vous
découvre aujourd'hui à l'antenne
auparavant je vous propose d'écouter
françois simeoni c'est lui qui vous a
succédé à la tête du front national dans
le département des yvelines écoutez
c'est le propre d'un grand parti
finalement d'avoir des dissidents quand
on était peu nombreux on était soudée et
que quand on a quand on devient une
formation politique importante
il est anormal que il y ait ce genre de
phénomène et des dissidences en j'avais
mois signalé le travail qui avait fait
philippe chevrier sur le département
je pense qu'il a fait un bon travail
maintenant aller se présenter contre des
candidats du front national
je pense que c'est contreproductif pour
l'intérêt de la nation
mais bon ça peut nous faire de l'enfant
vous craignez que véritablement
je ne pense pas je pense que le résultat
risque de très décevant pour lui
françois simeoni qui sera l'invité du
7-8 politique de cette semaine françois
simeoni qui salue votre travail
néanmoins mais il estime que vous
n'allez pas obtenir de bons résultats et
que c'est même contre productif on va
donner on verra pour les résultats bons
contre-productif contre-productif pour
pourquoi pour qui
pour le front national je ne sais pas tu
as an l'idée n'est pas de se présenter
contre le front national comme il a
l'air de deux le sous-entendent mais
plutôt de mettre sur le tapis un certain
nombre d'idées qui nous paraissent
original qui ne sont pas reprises par
d'autres partis et donc c'est une voie
que qui restent ouvertes pour pour les
personnes qui souhaitent adhérer à ce
parti et faire faire
en sorte que c'est que ces valeurs
soient soient mises en avant et donc
exerce le pouvoir une certaine manière
dit que ce n'est pas contre le front
national la création de ce front libéré
néanmoins vous avez des mots assez durs
envers votre ancienne formation
politique puisque vous dites que le
front national est aujourd'hui aux
portes du pouvoir mais par défaut tout
simplement parce que le système actuel
gauche comme droite s'écroule c'est pas
très dur
en fait c'est juste un constat c'est
vrai que la gauche et la droite n'existe
plus la gauche est complètement divisé
la droite malheureusement engluée dans
les affaires
donc les gens ils ont le choix entre
s'abstenir ou voter front national voilà
c'est à peu près et c'est pour ça que ça
monte beaucoup en ce moment je vais
rappeler vous avez tout de même été
écarté du fonds national pour avoir
participé à un rassemblement organisé
par jean marie le pen ce qui avait été
défendu par la présidence justement par
marine le pen qui souhaitaient l'union
autour plutôt de sa personne plutôt que
du président d'honneur à l'époque du
parti vous ne regrettez pas votre choix
d'ailleurs de ce soutien à jean marie le
pen
ah non pas du tout je veux renouveler
d'ailleurs mais je vous disais que ça
avait été interdite par marine le pen
en vérité non c'est mettant des
conseillers en tous cas par d'autres
mais pas par elle est précisément c'est
un peu le problème c'est que d'abord en
tant que secrétaire départemental
n'avait reçu aucune instruction de ne
pas y aller alors que d'habitude c'est
le cas pour une manifestation x ou y est
ensuite marine le pen ne s'était pas
exprimée elle même sur le sujet par
contre d'autres cadres effectivement du
front national avait fortement dit dans
l'est dans les médias que il fallait pas
y aller bon mais moi je ne pouvais pas
comprendre que marine le pen est en
n'ayant rien dit on ne puisse pas aller
au 1er mai de son père quitte à aller
aux siens après puisque il était
justement décalée d'une donc voila
c'était le site et pas du tout contre le
front national ou contre marine le pen
donc qu'effectivement j'ai effectivement
j'ai pas bien compris la décision qui a
été prise et aujourd'hui et n'est donc
se feront elles libérées qui vous a
rejoint finalement des anciens aussi du
département du front national est
essentiellement sur une cinquantaine
on démarre même a connu grâce à vous
j'espère que je n'aurai beaucoup plus
mais le timing est assez court
finalement pour se lancer dans la course
aux prochaines législatives
oui bah écoutez on souhaite démarrer
maintenant voilà qu'elle soit retardé de
plusieurs années
quelles sont vos ambitions justement
pour les législatives déjà à écouter
pour les législatives on souhaite avoir
trois candidats déjà dans le département
si on peut ensuite ajustée sur les
yvelines sur les hauts-de-seine
également et puis si on peut faire 5 %
peut-être sur les hauts-de-seine on va
voir il faut et si on peut faire 5%
ce serait très bien pour un début et
ensuite votre ligne de mire aussi les
sénatoriales c'est ce que vous décriez
aussi aussi bien sûr bien sûr puisqu'on
est maintenant connue par un certain
nombre de maires les uns et les autres
donc oui pourquoi pas on va revenir sur
quelques points du programme pour
poursuivre cet entretien vous souhaitez
à quitter l'euro par exemple l'union
européenne ça aussi on retrouve au front
national
qu'est ce qui fait votre différence sur
ce point là à moi je la retrouve plus
haut sur nationale senior je pensais que
ça allait y était effectivement c'était
une des raisons d'ailleurs de mon
adhésion au front national
mais aujourd'hui j'ai des doutes sérieux
parce que franchement quand vous êtes
convaincu que quelque chose d'aussi
important
vous avez quand même pas demander ou
peur de vous confirmer dans cette
intention
parce que sinon enfin ça veut ça veut
dire que vous n'êtes pas convaincu alors
si vous n'êtes pas convaincu alors à ce
moment là il ya un problème vous êtes
convaincus de quoi où allez-vous en est
la france
donc les saisons de groland homme sur sa
grande joie ou n'y est pas favorable il
ya un grand flou du front national
autour de la question de l'euro et sur
la juste pour revenir sur cette question
des référendums pour solliciter le
référendum peuple pourquoi bien ce soit
sur cette question là paraît sûr mais
enfin sur cette question qui est très
clivante
à partir du moment où vous présenter
avec ce programme là donc vous êtes élu
vous n'allez pas redemander au peuple
que de confirmer votre élection c'est du
dernier véhicule
j'ajoute que ça ressemble un peu à abon
je me présente pour sortir de l'euro
mais s'il vous plaît empêcher moi de
faire quoi donc votez non s'il vous
plaît voilà ça ressemble un peu à ça ça
ressemble à un coup à la cipra ce bon
je comprends pas je trouve que c'est
assez anxiogène donc ça ça concerne
l'euro et l'europe
la sortie de l'euro en tout cas le reste
sur le plan du travail par exemple quels
sont les points de programme que points
de programme pardon que vous mettez en
avant
je pense à la retraite à 65 ans 42
annuités fixer la durée légale du
travail à 39 heures payées 39 aussi fait
partie de vos points de programme oui
une certaine rigueur budgétaire car je
pense que si on sort de l'euro il faut
en même temps avoir une grande rigueur
budgétaire car sinon c'est effectivement
la planche à billets c'est effectivement
l'inflation c'est effectivement la
dégradation de la monnaie bon tout un
tas de choses qui risque au bout du bout
d'amener des catastrophes
donc pour éviter ça il faut que
effectivement on sorte de l'euro mais
qu'on en ait une en tout cas un objectif
d'équilibré budgétaire très strictes
c'est ça c'est fondamental
et si on le fait il n'y a aucune raison
que les marchés monétaires agissent
contre le cette nouvelle monnaie il ya
aucune raison au contraire france est un
grand pays avec une production de 2200
milliards
une épargne de 12000 milliards
il n'y a aucune raison que les marchés
monétaires se se concentre sur sûr sur
cette monnaie ne sur le plant pour la
faire baisser
par contre ce qui risque d'arriver c'est
que le reste de la de l'europe sur la
zone marquant relire qui resterait elle
va sans doute se revaloriser s'apprécier
sur les marchés monétaires voient la
diren la théorie d'ensemble
de d'économique nous défendons il ya un
autre point qui est important dans votre
programme c'est celui de l'immigration
je vais en citer quelques quelques
extraits de ce sept lignes directrices
de votre formation le front libérer tout
immigré en greg il devra respecter les
us et coutumes de du pays d'accueil
exercer un métier démontrer sa volonté
de s'assimiler aussi la tenue
vestimentaire qui respecte les us et
coutumes de la france lors du voile
sarah lentement un premier en ce qu'il
faut ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'on
n'est pas contre l'immigration dans le
principe mais que les migrations se
justifie quand on a besoin de main
d'oeuvre qualifiée ou pas d'ailleurs
peu importe mais il faut qu'il y ait ce
besoin demain si on n'a pas de besoins
de main d'oeuvre et c'est pas le cas
actuellement il sauf peut-être dans
quelques parties particularité quelques
métiers particuliers bon mais sinon
grosse grossièrement on n'a pas besoin
de l'immigration aujourd'hui c'est pour
ça qu'il faut être prêt ce trait en
matière d'immigration mais elles ont
plutôt si en cas de perte de travail de
plus de six mois ou deux condamnations
pénales l'immigré qui même en règle sera
reconduit dans son plan de rayonnement
il faut il faut être
il faut être strict point de vue là rien
immigré en règle qui n'a plus de travail
pendant plus de six mois
écoutez voit tout et la france qu'est ce
qui peut faire ghs qu'il ya est ce qu'il
ya une justification de le garder en
france non l'émigration se justifie pour
une immigration de travail s'ils
retravaillent ont reconduit à la
frontière tout simplement merci philippe
chevrier donc président du front libéré
mouvement qui vient de se lancer dans le
département qui entend présenter des
candidats aux législatives on aura
l'occasion bien sûr de reparler dans les
prochaines semaines merci à vous le ser
site invités se poursuit
un nouveau festival voit le jour à saint
quentin en yvelines les instances et
c'est son nom il a été lancée par
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines c'est le chef du projet à
qui nous en dit plus qu'est ce que le
festival insensé alors au tout début
initialement les faits c'est à la france
et c'est un projet étudiant qui s'est
monté sur le premier semestre de l'année
puisque une équipe d'étudiants qui se
ment en m2 de management des
organisations culturelles et artistiques
donc en deux mots qu'a et d'en quête de
cm2 on nous a demandé d'imaginer de
penser un projet est celui qu'on voulait
donc nous on a décidé de monter un
projet de territoire qui est un festival
pluridisciplinaire artistique sur saint
quentin en yvelines et plus
particulièrement sur le campus de 50 ans
et avec la maison de l'étudiant qui un
nouvel équipement qui vient de se créer
au sein d'universités
ça commence le 24 mars ça court jusqu'au
26 trois jours il va se passer quoi
alors ça commence le 24 mars à 20h de
20h à 23h à peu près équivalent ailleurs
des concerts des spectacles
d'ailleurs des ateliers participatifs
une table ronde sur la culture qu'on
espère évidemment à voir on espère avoir
beaucoup de personnes qui vont
participer et un bal populaire le
dimanche après midi qui prend place
puisqu'on imagine touche quand même plus
un public familial le dimanche après
midi alors que le samedi soir on a
plutôt une formule de soirée électro
plutôt à destination des étudiants de
l'université puisqu'on aussi en
partenariat avec le bureau des arts de
l'estaca donc dans ce grand pôle paris
sa classe et nous on a voulu aussi
aujourd'hui pouvoir créer une dynamique
des servantes rennes dynamique
collective avec les associations locales
les associations étudiantes les
partenaires institutionnels la
communauté d'agglomération les communes
autour pour vraiment créer un réseau
culturel avec toutes ces associations
dans l'idée de monter un projet et de
pérenniser puisque on espère que insensé
première édition verra une seconde
édition
si la première se déroule bien vous avez
fait mention à plusieurs reprises
d'autres associations n'ont qu'à un
petit mot
non de quelques unes d'entre elles
bonsoir notre partenaire principal c'est
donc l'association anima sauce une sorte
de collectif d'associations qui réunit
elle même beaucoup d'associations parmi
lesquels b 3.1 donc anciennement black
blanc beur le théâtre du sable avec et
yann guichard faire nos partenaires sur
sur l'événement sky dans sa session de
danse de chant les falbalas et
abracadabra de guyancourt et ensuite en
partenaire autres on a aussi évidemment
les partenaires institutionnels de
l'université sam soutenu par le crous
par le fonds de soutien des initiatives
étudiantes pareils cher aussi qu' une
grosse étude sur la santé des étudiants
qui est sur lui vécu et sur bordeaux et
on a encore d'autres partenaires que
vous pourrez découvrir au sein du
festival
vous parlez de balle vous parlez de
spectacle peut-être la présentation d'un
ou deux événements même si c'est
compliqué de choisir surtout ce qui va
se passer pendant trois jours bon bah
alors assez naturellement je vais
choisir leur dire de l'événement
d'ouverture qui ont le spectacle
d'improvisation fait par déclic théâtre
par un de leurs troupes donc qui sont
les épices qui sera présent du 20h à
21h30 le vendredi et 24 mars donc sur le
site du festival
s'il fait suffisamment bon et beau ce
sera sous le chapiteau sinon ce sera à
l'intérieur évidemment le bal populaire
parce que c'est quand même un moment qui
va s'étirer sur la longueur le dimanche
de 13h30 à 17h avec des ateliers
participatifs d'initiation à certains
types de danse pendant l'après midi et
pour prendre un autre exemple on peut
parler aussi du samedi matin de 11h à
12h30 sts nous faisons une parade dans
les rues de saint quentin en yvelines
avec l'ensemble de batucada la scara
bond de la verrière et derrière
plusieurs bombes d'associations qui vont
faire des stops donc des arrêts avec des
petits shows dans saint quentin en
yvelines avec vivre debout
ou kelly burden de billancourt et voilà
y a pas d'association comme ça qu'ils
participent
c'est la fin du set 8 invités replay sur
notre site internet et sur notre
application mobile très belle soirée
[Musique]